frappé de plein fouet par la pandémie de
kobe 19
l'espagne connaît un net ralentissement
de son activité économique depuis l'état
dallas décrété le 14 mars et le
confinement strict l'espagne a
enregistré une hausse record de son
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi espagne
aujourd'hui l'espagne connaît une
augmentation du nombre de chômeurs
enregistrés de 300 2265 personnes il
s'agit d'une augmentation absolument
exceptionnel par rapport au mois
précédent c'est une augmentation par
rapport au mois précédent que nous
qualifions d'historique
mais ce n'est pas historique pour le
nombre total de chômeurs comme vous le
savez ces chiffres représentent une
hausse de plus de 9% par rapport au mois
de février le nombre de contrats de
travail signés en mars a chuté de plus
de 26% par rapport à mars 2019
le gouvernement a annoncé qu'il
garantirait jusqu'à 100 milliards
d'euros de prêts aux entreprises pour
les aider durant cette crise ainsi que
d'autres mesures de soutien
nos chefs pouvait le coït 19 ne peut pas
être utilisé comme justification pour
des licenciements
en ce sens nous adoptons des mesures
législatives pour rendre impossible le
recours au licenciement pour des raisons
de force majeure techniques économiques
organisationnelles et de production il
ne sera plus possible de licencier car
comme vous le savez nous mettons en
place des mécanismes juridiques et
d'importantes ressources publiques pour
que l'on puisse recourir au chômage
partiel
si on est en plein dans le même temps
madrid a suspendu l'expulsion de
locataire jusqu'à six mois après la fin
de l'état d' alerte
il en va de même pour les fournisseurs
d'électricité de gaz et d'eau qu'ils ne
peuvent pas interrompre les prestations
fournies aux résidences principales des
citoyens parallèlement à cette
augmentation drastique du chômage
l'industrie espagnole s'adapte et se
joint à la lutte contre le coronavirus
c'est le cas du constructeur automobile
seat qui a adapté un de ces sites pour y
assembler des respirateurs artificiels
de son côté une entreprise d'imprimantes
3d fabrique des visières médicale
nous avons lancé un projet pour lequel
notre pack d'imprimantes composé de 63
machines imprime 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 des visières 3d muni d'un
écran protecteur et nous les envoyons
gratuitement et sans poser de questions
aux hôpitaux espagnols qui déclarent en
décembre l'espagne affiché un taux de
chômage de 13 18% selon l'institut
national de la statistique
soit le taux le plus élevé de la zone
euro après la grèce